okay we're going to take a break from
heavy or controversial or any of that
stuff we're just going to have some fun
so I don't usually do any kind of
prediction speculation anything like
that really at all it's something I've
never really gotten into and I don't
know what made me want to just sort of
throw my thoughts about what I think is
coming down the pipe for Game of Thrones
but why not let's give it a go and I'm
going to just jump around and obviously
spoilers for anyone who's not caught up
and recording this as of the first
episode of series 7 having aired so
that's where I am as I'm saying this
stuff and I want to get the top before
any more episodes air so we can see if
any of this stuff is going to happen so
let's talk about some characters and
whether or not they're going to live I
want to start with the one that I am
most certain is going to be dead by the
end of this season and that's Cersei
Cersei Lannister there's no way she's
making it to the end of this season
because it's just it's a practical thing
because right now she is kind of the
major human villain who had left I mean
there's there's a ton of smaller scale
very compromised or compromising
characters like euros Littlefinger so on
but she's at the head of the heap right
now and she kind of has to be dealt with
so that in the last season which is
going to be the next season we get after
this one the focus can be on the White
Walkers and dealing with that now that's
not me saying all sides will unite as
one
not necessarily backstabbing though
it'll still be a mess but I think if
there if the just story forget what the
characters have to focus on but just
narrative Lee if it's going to really
make that struggle epic it needs to kind
of clear this off the board much in the
same way that having the red wedding
sort of removed the distraction of just
Starks versus Lannisters it made you
realize oh everything was bigger than
that so they got rid of this -
distractingly small and petty for you to
make you realise this story is much
bigger kind
the same way we got to get seriously
gone so that we can deal with the final
conflict primarily in the last season so
I say she goes now the question then
becomes how does she die are I suppose
more specifically who's going to kill
her well there's a couple of options as
far as that goes I think I don't know if
he's the most likely but he's kind of
the one I'm pulling for and that's Jamie
I think Cersei is going to go full-on
Mad King I think she is just going to
wield the power she has like a cudgel
and she's going to start doing so much
damage and that once it becomes clear
that they need to unite to fight against
the night king and she won't do it and
her refusal to do it is going to
endanger the entire nation of Westeros I
think Jamie's going to make the toughest
decision he will ever have to make and I
think he's gonna kill her he might not
he might not have the stones to do it he
might never get the opportunity to do it
he might do something to kill them both
because he know because maybe he would
know he couldn't live with himself after
having done it but we'll see other
options available for killing Cersei
obviously are you start want sir
and is going down to get her I I'm going
to come back to Arya overall um some
other choices maybe Sansa but I'm not
I'm not sure Sansa ending up down in
King's Landing again is really something
that is kind of in the cards I think she
would really desperately be avoiding
that unless something major shift so I
think those are the two best options
either Arya or Jamie I'm putting my
money on Jamie right now without that's
it's personal I suppose they could get
rid of her in a much bigger way time
much like she took out so many with that
explosion at the end of the last season
but I think is something like that I
mean the dragons could just come in and
then firebomb King's Landing and that'd
be it but I think there's going to want
to go smaller and more personal with
that one so I mentioned are you going to
come back to her I know a lot of people
who think she's not going to make it to
the end of the show I'm going to talk
when I talk about characters living not
living both up for the season and for
the show overall
maybe it's just because I desperately
don't want to see the stark suffer too
much more than they already have
here's what I'll say about aria her
story does not end happily I don't think
that necessarily means she has to die I
could see her either wrapping up her
sort of assassination mission or failing
to do it and then taking stock of what
she has become and what she's done just
basically leaving you know not no
goodbyes no and she just leaves because
she realizes she's not fit for the world
that is going to be rebuilt in the wake
of everything once the whole thing wraps
up so her story is going to end
unhappily I but again I don't think it
requires her to die though that may
still happen I do think she's far too
damaged to just be sticking around after
this John I think John's going to make
it to the end of the show if for no
other reason then we killed him once
already killing him again is not going
to have the same kind of impact it's
just not Daenerys I think probably I
would I would be swell and if Daenerys
goes it's going to be like massive blaze
of glory like her facing down the night
king or something but I think she makes
it tyrion is probably going to die
I think Tyrion is and but I don't think
Aaron's going to dyn's of a last season
but I do think he's probably going to
die he's probably going to have like a
big noble moment or actually you know
what I need to backtrack now I could see
Tyrion Kieran killing Searcy I could see
that one happening if he got the chance
but I don't I don't see Tyrion making it
to the very end I'll tell you what it's
it's tough to call and I'm jumping
around I'm going to keep jumping around
there's lots of characters I'm not going
to talk about and I'm just going to keep
going till I run out of steam I'll tell
you a character and I say this and it
sounds like a joke or wishlist but kind
of serious I want lady Mormont to end up
on the Iron Throne at the end of all
this because think about it at the
unless they're just going to break up
the kingdoms and have them all be ruled
individually by the local families which
probably what Daenerys would want but if
someone is actually going to rule if the
Iron Throne is just not flat-out
destroyed which now that I'm saying that
maybe it would be that would make sense
but if it isn't who's gonna rule John is
not really a ruler John you know he's a
warrior he can lead soldiers he's not
ruler for a kingdom Daenerys I don't
know I did a very much wants to upset
status quo and change everything I'm not
sure how much she wants to be in charge
once that happens lady more months I
think that is one person there Daenerys
could be on board with taking over that
seat and I for one oh I love that
I really would um so who else we got I
mentioned Jamie yeah I think I've said
everything I'm already going to say
about Jamie the hound
okay the hound has to kill Franken
Mountain I mean he just does that they
have to face lot of each other and again
I don't think they're going to kill the
Hound just because like John he went he
went presumed dead and for a longer
stretch of time so to bring in bag just
to kill him again
I guess not that this show is like
somehow above disappointing its audience
but it does it never does it in a
masochistic way which is kind of the way
the Walking Dead goes about killing off
characters so I think that he's going to
get that face off because I think a lot
of us kind of felt that ah when you know
the mountain kind of died but then came
back and then it looked like the Hound
was dead there's like oh we're never
going to get that face off between them
well they're both still alive now in
some form so we that fight has to happen
and he needs to win Oh general think
coming back to Arya I think everyone's
calling this already if you paid
attention to the next time on Game of
Thrones yes she's going to run into
Nymeria that's probably having happen
next episode which is a pleasant
surprise because I had a video I did a
couple years ago about dangling plot
threads that I actually was expecting
but never going to get tied up Nymeria
was one of them so that makes me happy
to see that finally come back or yeah I
presume it is say I kind of taking it as
a foregone conclusion at this point
Sansa I don't know I'm [ __ ] something
could really go one of two ways right
now and I know what I would like to have
happened I know what I'm afraid is going
to happen what I would like to have
happened is that you know the fact that
her experience is so vastly different
from John's is that John recognizes the
value of what she brings to the table
the two of them work together cuz
they're basically like each one half of
like the best ruler ever bigger just
work in conjunction he has all the
nobility she has a lot of political
savvy at this point because of what
she's seen in what she's been through
what I'm afraid is going to happen is
that she is going to come to the
conclusion that John is too pigheaded to
do things that she views as being
necessary and she's going to fall in
with Littlefinger and they're going to
do things to make us hate her and I
really don't want them to do that
because it took a long time for me to
like Sansa like again years ago I did
this list this Addie's lists are all out
of date but when I did a list a while
back of my least favorite characters
Sansa was on it and at the time I that
was a very sincere placement she
wouldn't make that list now I really
enjoy her as the character but it took a
long time for me to like her could we
not just fall over there I'm going to
make the call that Brienne is not going
to die because it's just for me it fits
the kind of the weird sometimes poetic
irony of the world of Westeros which is
that she as the shining knight is by far
probably the one most willing to die for
any given cause that she's in but I
think in a way that almost makes it
bizarrely fitting if she never did
because she's the one most willing to
lay her life on the line but she'll
survive at the end I'm not sure Samwell
makes it past the end of this season
because he's getting the information on
that library now and
why is that got to kind of be his
function fulfilled the story's not going
to need him after that I think he might
go I think they might cut him as
deadweight and there's an easy solution
to that his father you know tracks him
down and catches up with him and then
that whole thing goes sour bet you they
kill each other
benjin's gonna have to die like for real
dying for my money a brand has to kill
him because it's going to be like a
weird
he starts falling under the control of
the night's king and and you know brand
who was saved by him is gonna have to be
the one to end his life something along
those lines I flip a coin on whether or
not Brandon brand makes it through this
season next season he might go lady
Elena Terrell not sure she's not making
it through the season she's going to see
Searcy she's got it out live Searcy
I'm going to say that um that she's
going to see since I brought down and
laid low after that yeah I don't think
she dies but she kind of will
effectively eggs up the story because
once we get into taking on the White
Walkers there won't be anything for her
to do Dorne I don't know I don't care
you know the sand snakes and that woman
who is taking over the kingdom I just
don't care I guess they died maybe they
maybe they either piss off Daenerys or
maybe they just end up being fodder for
the White Walkers just to show us it's
all getting real now brahms gonna live
because bronze not noble and he knows
when to run away from a fight bran lives
Betsy he's not even there at the final
confrontation stuff next season I would
really like for Davos to live so that he
can just be the new right hand of
whoever is left standing to run stuff
Faris I don't know what's the more
political intrigue and the things is
wrapped up he kind of won't have
anything to do kind of a bit like Lady
Elaine in that way a little finger
little fingers gonna die he has to die
I think sands has got to kill him even
if he manages like bring her under his
sway or whatever he's going to do
something that's going to
a breaking point for her and she's gonna
kill him and lastly Euron's gonna die
and Theon's got to kill him defending
Yara so there we go
that's all of that it just felt nice to
just do something that's just fun and
just throw stuff out there not have to
think really carefully about the
implication of everything I'm talking
about am i using my words correctly am i
properly expressing is that no let's
just keep fun who's gonna lose going to
die what are your thoughts on any of the
stuff I said any characters I forgot to
mention what do you think is going to go
down whatever you see I think part of
the reason I didn't like to do
speculation of Game of Thrones before is
because there were people who could have
read the book who go to suppose stuff
for me you can't do it now how high you
highfalutin readers in any case I don't
know where that came from that was weird
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down on the continents let's
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council geeks
give a listen to the council of geeks
podcast available on iTunes and stitcher
I am also one half of the punch like a
girl podcast also available on iTunes
and stitcher until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]